my pleasure and i must say i've been
really impressed by all your questions
it showed that you did prepare and
read papers and think about it
and that's very much appreciated um
thank you
today is an incredibly special occasion
we have professor joshua benjio on the
show just honestly i just can't get over
it but um
first of all a little bit of
housekeeping so um we've just launched a
new discord community so please jump in
there say hello introduce yourself um if
you want to be um you know part of the
moderating
community or just help us do stuff over
there we would love to talk with you by
popular demand we've also added a couple
of ways in which you can support us so
we now have a patreon and a merch store
if you're interested in supporting some
of the episodes of mlst then get in
touch with us because we'd love to have
a conversation with you we're just doing
so much cool stuff this year we've
already recorded about six episodes that
we haven't released and we've got some
amazing people booked as well so yeah
it's gonna be incredible um as always if
you like the content here please
consider hitting the like and subscribe
button and rating our podcast on itunes
because it really really helps us out um
i called it itunes is it itunes
apple podcasts i don't know whatever
it's called
weights and biases is the developer
first mlops platform and we're extremely
proud today that they are sponsoring
this episode
now tracking machine learning
experiments is difficult using the
winging it methodology can only get you
so far what we need is a platform where
we can compare models and visualize
their performance characteristics
against all of the previous runs and
figure out the best type of parameters
to use now most importantly of all this
process needs to be reproducible sounds
like a tall order right well this is
exactly what the weights and biases
platform does for you
now you can even follow metrics from
long-running experiments in real time
i think it's really important to lean
into the complex interaction between
science and engineering in the ml devops
life cycle
data scientists need valuable feedback
and they need to communicate why they're
running given experiments and they need
to share their notes around the next
steps
reports keep this work well organized
and connected to the weights and biases
experiments which were run as opposed to
just sharing random screenshots in slack
it's so easy to create a report and
share it with your team after you've
finished with your experimentation you
could just add notes for yourself as
well to explore later on you can keep a
work log and you can even share your
findings internally or externally this
is an absolute game changer i'm a big
believer in this kind of engineering
rigor i'm the ceo of a code review
startup called merge these days and i
love how the pull request process and
tooling immortalizes important
collective decisions which were made
during the software development life
cycle similarly weights and biases
immortalize as important decisions that
were made during model development
experimentation and deployment remember
check out weights and biases today by
going to 1db.com forward slash mlst and
if you're interested in sponsoring
future episodes get in touch with us
waiting biases are currently sponsoring
our premiere shows but we have lots of
other content coming and opportunities
for sponsorship so let us know um cheers
professor yahshua benjo has just
released a bunch of papers around g-flow
nets now g-flow nets exists squarely in
the domain of active learning which is a
model that can economically ask an
oracle which is probably the real world
for the most salient training examples
to continue learning
the learner can choose or have an
influence on the examples it gets and we
want to learn a function which
approximates the oracle efficiently how
should we pick the queries how should we
take into account not just the value of
the predictor but also how certain we
are about the predictors from the
learning system
areas of uncertainty or entropy are kind
of like interesting candidates for us to
explore further we need to be able to
imagine or invent queries to give to the
oracle now one of the reasons that
machine learning models are so sample
and efficient is because of the
combinatorial space of possible input
examples we can't train on everything
because the space is just too large it's
vast
so you might have heard of a related
concept of active learning called
machine teaching which is an interactive
version where the human interactively
selects the most salient data to train a
machine learning model maximizing the
information gain in respect of the
training samples
now
the reality is the function space that
we're learning here is highly structured
we only really need to sample training
data where most of the rich information
exists in that function space i mean if
you think about it a machine learning
model it's just a joint probability
distribution between signals and labels
and this distribution
has modes or
areas of density or information and
actually most of it is just areas of
nothingness
which require fewer training examples to
learn and to represent
now
if you spoke to a uh to a bayesian
person like my friend conor tan at work
um you know how to learn this
distribution they would bring up markov
chain monte carlo quicker than a whippet
with a bum full of dynamite
now markov chain monte carlo is an
increasingly popular sampling method for
obtaining asymptotic information about
unnormalized distributions or energy
functions especially for estimating the
posterior distribution in bayesian
inference which is where you've probably
heard of it before
now you can characterize a distribution
without knowing all of the distributions
mathematical properties so if you don't
have an analytical representation for it
just by randomly sampling values out of
the distribution
now um a particular strength of markov
chain monte carlo is that it can be used
to draw samples from distributions even
when all that is known about the
distribution is how to calculate the
density for different samples
now the um the markov property of markov
chain monte carlo is this idea that
random samples are generated by a
special sequential process and each
random sample is used as a stepping
stone to generate the next random sample
now
this might sound very complex but the
practical implementation is pretty
simple markov chain monte carlo just
starts with an initial guess just one
value that might plausibly be drawn from
the distribution and then we produce a
chain of samples from this initial guess
by adding random perturbations
in the neighborhood of that example and
each new proposal and drawn from that
random perturbation distribution is
either rejected or accepted um there are
different flavors of this of course i
mean in particular like tweaking
how the random proposals in the
neighborhood are selected or whether the
proposals are selected um the simplest
heuristic being whether it's below the
function or not
now the idea is that markov chain monte
carlo methods they capture a
distribution with only a relatively
small number of random samples but the
reality is anything but
in high dimensions and where the
distribution has many modes spread far
apart it's actually exponentially
expensive um there's a bunch of human
orientated hacks to try and make this
work well in specific cases but we're
missing a much more general machine
learnable solution this is the main
reason why we haven't seen it used in
many machine learning applications yet
assuming that the function we want to
learn has underlying structure then we
can escape the exponential time of
markov chain monte carlo with machine
learning and this is what bengio calls
systematic generalization which is to
say how do we generalize far from the
data in a way which is meaningful
now g flow nets are an active learning
framework where the name of the game is
to generate salient and diverse training
data to augment our model in the most
sample efficient way possible for g-flow
nets to work we need a reward function
and a deterministic episodic environment
does that sound familiar yes just like
reinforcement learning now a flow
network is a directed graph with sources
and sinks and edges carrying some amount
of flow between them you know through
intermediate nodes so i think a good way
to think about this is pipes of water
now for our purposes we define a flow
network with a single source um so the
root nodes or you might say the sinks of
the network correspond to the terminal
states now it's designed to find the
possible trajectories through our system
okay and just think of alpha zero as
being like a good analogy for these
trajectories
now the um training objective is to make
them approximately sample in proportion
to the given reward function this is in
stark contrast to alpha zero where we
were sampling to maximize the expected
reward so bengio's big idea is that we
could have an interacting loop between a
generative model and the real world the
real world is expensive so why not train
an imagination machine in our mind until
we're ready and waiting to produce good
questions to the real world we could use
imagined experiments to train our
generator
then produce queries to the real world
we were thinking about a way to
visualize how g-flow nets work when the
idea of a galton board came to mind
a galton board also known as a bean
machine
is a common prop in statistics courses
science museums and fun gadget stores
the board has rows of interleaved pegs
above a bottom row of buckets
beads are filled into a funnel at the
top of the board and then sprinkled on
the top center peg
the beads bounce either to the left or
to the right as they hit the pegs and
eventually collect into buckets at the
bottom
if the pegs are precisely and
symmetrically arranged the beads will
aggregate at the bottom into a familiar
binomial bell curve
now imagine that the pegs were instead
flow gates
with adjustable valves that could direct
the beads more to the left or more to
the right
to bias the flow paths
with such a machine you could adjust the
valves or flow rates to create any
distribution
for example to create a uniform
distribution we'd open up the gates
flowing away from the center line of the
board to drive more bead flow to the
fewer number of paths leading to the
edges and the corners
or to create a multi-modal distribution
we'd arrange the gates to split the
flows into two or more streams that
would then pile up in multiple humps or
modes below
there's a lot of flexibility here
indeed given a distribution there are
generally multiple flow gate solutions
to produce it it'd be nice wouldn't it
if we had an intelligent principled way
to train these gates
inter g flow nets
g flow nets put a neural network a brain
behind the flow adjustments a brain
which can optimize the gates to match
any distribution we desire
here we are interested in sampling a
reward function in the context of
reinforcement learning
in that context this is a powerful
simulation and sampling paradigm
you see once the brain has tuned the
flow weights such a modified galton
board or more generally a flow network
can sample diverse paths quickly and
efficiently
leading to the reward distribution
it's important to point out that the
path sampling is more diverse doing it
this way
unlike classic reinforcement learning a
g-flow net doesn't just fixate on a
small number of high-reward paths it
happens to find first
instead it stochastically samples a
broad spectrum of paths in proportion to
their reward
sure high reward paths will be sampled
with higher weight but the far larger
population of low reward paths will get
a share of the sampling as well
why should we even bother with such
paths
the answer is we need to balance
exploitation or high reward with
exploration or learning to better learn
the reward function
this is especially important when
dealing with complex real-world
scenarios of high uncertainty
for example think of molecular drug
discovery and design or navigating
jungle terrain
in both those scenarios we really know
very little about how a particular path
may play out
we might stumble into the next miracle
cure or a pitfall of quicksand
to find the globally best paths it's
important to keep our options open
beyond this sampling diversity g-flow
nets also bring the full power of neural
networks to discover latent structure
and learn the reward function
this combined with their diverse
sampling
also makes g flow nets more robust when
dealing with multimodal distributions
which are a common trap for greedy
algorithms
and markov chain monte carlo
if there is structure linking the
multiple nodes
g-flow nuts can learn it and extrapolate
to new modes and once discovered they
will by design
drive the sampling to cover those modes
and learn more structure
overall g-flow nets seem to offer an
intriguing new
path
pun intended for an intelligent sampling
paradigm
so you might ask how are g flow nets
different from alpha zero well the
policy network and alpha zero gives you
a set of actions given a state alpha
zero trains the policy network to
maximize reward so that the trajectories
all end up at the highest reward now
what g flow nets do is they train so
that the actions are distributed in
proportion to the reward so rather than
pruning away all of the low reward
trajectories it will sample them just
less often
now there is a a manifest difference
between g flow nets in respect of
exploration i mean you might argue that
the monte carlo tree search is still
doing wide exploration at the beginning
but in spite of its rapid convergence
and pruning of low reward trajectories
it's still sampling from the underlying
probability distribution which has been
scaled with a softmax so there's
actually not that much to explore in the
first place
so in summary g flow nets are better
than alpha zero monte carlo research in
some sense because they achieve the same
goal by offloading the burn in time and
the stabilization time of markov chain
monte carlo remember this whole thing
can be trained offline and then when in
inference mode we can do it in a single
shot whereas with monte carlo research
we actually had to do it
in inference mode as well
um the other thing is we're kind of um
offloading all of the human engineering
required to sample efficiently from
markov chain monte carlo and the other
thing is diversity baby i mean consider
the difference between how g flow nets
and alpha zero sample the reward path
distribution if you looked at the
distributions you would see that alpha
zero has a little box around the mode g
flow nets is the whole distribution we
know very well that diversity
preservation is critical in order to
discover interesting stepping stones in
search problems
now finally benjio has published results
showing the g flow nets converge
exponentially faster than markov chain
monte carlo and ppo on some problems and
finds more of the modes in the
distribution function faster
enjoy the show folks
professor joshua benjio is recognized
worldwide as one of the leading experts
in artificial intelligence indeed a
godfather of deep learning his
pioneering work in deep learning earned
him the touring award which is the nobel
prize of computing he's a full professor
at the university of montreal and the
founder and scientific director of miele
which is a prestigious community of more
than 900 researchers specializing in
machine learning and ai
he's one of the most cited computer
scientists on the planet and i can't
even begin to articulate how honored we
are today to have this conversation
joshua has done a lot of work recently
on g flow nets which are an active
learning framework in a reinforcement
learning configuration where the name of
the game is to request salient and
diverse training data from the real
world to augment our learned models in
the most sample efficient way possible
now we're trying to minimize the
divergence between the path distribution
and the reward distribution and then
sample paths according to the reward
distribution this is in stark contrast
with traditional reinforcement learning
where we're trying to maximize the
expected reward
this approach is likely to find diverse
strategies instead of being greedy and
converging quickly after finding a
single one anyway professor benjio this
is amazing can you tell us about this
exciting work in some of its
applications
yeah i'm i don't think i've been as
excited about a new topic uh
uh
at least in the last
six or seven years as i'm now with chief
lawnets
and
it's actually even much more than what
you've been talking about
the way i think about g flow nets is a
kind of
framework for generic
learnable
inference
for probabilistic machine learning
so
one way to think about this is
it's a learnable replacement for
multi-color markov chain sampling
but actually so there's that and i'll
explain if you want why this is
important and and to use machine
learning there but but also
it can be used to estimate
probabilities themselves so not just
sampling but also estimate uh
intractable quantities like partition
functions and uh
conditional probabilities that would
otherwise require summing over an
intractable number of terms
um so i i think of this as these
potentially you know there's still uh
we're still at the beginnings of this
has a swiss army knife
of probabilistic modeling that uses
machine learning to be able to do things
that look intractable
but do them efficiently thanks to
generalization power of large neural
nets
we've been trying to think of a way to
help our listeners uh visualize um what
a what a g flow net does
and i wanted to run by a possibility to
you so i'm not sure if you've heard of
um galton boards also called uh you know
bean machines and what they are is is
this prop that's often used by
statistics professors at the start of
say an elementary introductory course to
give a visual intuition and it's a board
that has these vertical buckets down at
the bottom
with interleaved rows of pegs
above the buckets and then beads are
filled in
uh into the top of the board and they
bounce either left or right as they hit
the pegs and they eventually collect
down at the bottom yeah yeah yeah now
now if the peg very good analogy except
that it's not a tree i don't know how
these things are but you know the ball
can come
to a place from two different paths or
in potentially large number of paths
right right and i think um
given given there are some some
differences you know the idea was that
if the pegs
it's pretty close to exactly what it is
yeah and what we were thinking is that
if the pegs on the galton board are
precisely and symmetrically arranged you
know the beads will form a nice binomial
curve
at the bottom and it seems like what g
flow nets
are capable of doing when they optimize
the pathways
they're tweaking the pegs a little bit
to the left or a little to the right to
bias the flow of beads one way or the
other and in this way a g flow net could
arrange the pegs so that the beads could
form any distribution at the bottom that
we want and for our purposes that means
a distribution that matches the reward
function so is this a good way to think
about g-formats yes it is now it's
missing a really important aspect of it
which would be difficult to present
uh visually but that all of these uh peg
weights
like the quality of the ball goes left
or right
are um
not just like learned independently like
a as a tabular machine learning but that
there's like one neural net
that knows about the locations
in this big board
as input and tells you know how much
relative weight should i you know go to
go left or right at this position so
the reason this is important is because
it allows virtualization because this
board is huge it's exponentially large
right so there's no way you're going to
learn
like a separate parameter for each of
these choices
and so you have this neural net or
potentially several neural nets but
that share allow you to share
uh
statistical strength as we call it uh
share information across all the
possible positions so that it can
generalize to places paths that it has
never seen from a finite number of
training trajectories that it sees while
it's being trained and that's crucial
otherwise you couldn't scale to large
problems which is really what we want to
do
professor benjo we spoke with professor
carl fristen about his free energy
principle and active inference which is
pretty much a bayesian flavored version
of reinforcement learning and he said
that while we need to maintain entropy
and stop models from increasing too much
in complexity we should balance entropy
with accuracy in a principled way and by
the way you can kind of think of it just
to the audience think of entropy as
keeping your options open but um
fristen uh thinks that the bellman-esque
idea of reinforcement learning which is
to say maximizing expected reward is the
objective is misguided and we should
instead perform inference over future
paths balancing expected reward of
relative entropy is there a connection
between these ideas i mean it seems like
g flow nets are sampling paths
proportional to the reward function that
will maintain as much entropy as the
reward function itself
yes yes exactly it's a translation of
the reward function
into machinery that can sample
uh you know the equivalent the
corresponding distribution
um so yeah i completely agree with what
carl was saying here
but as i said what's interesting is
um
we can do things with g flow nets uh in
principle like
we've done the math and some small scale
experiments that we have now a number of
papers we can do things that go beyond
sampling
but for example estimate entropy itself
so
entropy is
notoriously difficult to estimate
and um
you know i mentioned in in my talks on g
flow nets that we can use the g flow
that machinery
uh to estimate entropy of say an action
distribution or
a distribution over
bayesian parameters for example which is
would be something you'd like
to minimize if you're going to take an
action in the world
and you have a model of the world that
has uncertainty
uh and that connects well with carl for
instance interest
you'd like to be able to choose an
action that minimizes your uncertainty
about
how the world works we know what are the
latest things that may have happened
and a good you know an important part of
that is estimating the reward for the
the these these exploratory actions like
you know
children playing around is
how much
reduction in entropy of my knowledge of
the world am i going to get through that
action so you need to be able to compute
that reward and that word is basically
an entropy over something you care about
um and it turns out you can also do that
with g flow nets we're actually speaking
with fristen again next week do you have
a question that you would like us to put
to him
well um
he uh you know he's on the biology side
of things much more than i am and
i believe there are amazing
scientific opportunities to explore
how
um the kind of the
machinery that
g floyd nets offer
could be used by brains in order to do
some of the things they do
um using neural nets to model the
probabilistic structure of the world
including uncertainty which is something
he cares about
um but but also taking into
consideration things like high level
cognition the global workspace theory
which is something i care a lot about uh
attention they all kind of fit
in um
the the picture of g flow nets
um
so so i think there's a
huge potential of research at the
synergy of computational and theoretical
neuroscience
and machine learning
uh probabilistic modeling of the kind
that gfonets propose
to come up with a
some uh proposals for
explanatory theories about what the
brain does that's probabilistic
and you know i think uh he would be a
great person to be part of that uh
fascinating well um
going a little bit further down that
line there are folks in the community
who are huge advocates of biologically
inspired approaches to machine
intelligence and uh you know one of the
key ideas actually is diversity
discovery and preservation both in how
knowledge is acquired and represented i
mean specifically evolutionary algorithm
advocates they differentiate themselves
from gradient-based single-aged
monolithic approaches like reinforcement
learning and they point out that their
approaches overcome so-called deception
and search problems you know which is to
say they don't get stuck in local minima
your approach seems to be achieving
something very similar in the context of
a gradient-based reinforcement learning
package i mean i don't see it as being
mutually exclusive but what's your take
on this
yeah diversity is important when you are
exploring and and you know humans
especially young ones are exploration
machines they're trying to understand
how the world works and they're acting
in the world in order to get that
information
yeah i agree that
that search process needs to have a big
uh bonus on um on diversity like on
trying
different ways of achieving something
good like
better understanding how the world works
so um it turns out that in the g phonet
framework you
you have a
training objective that yields this kind
of diversity and exploration
but is based on training large neural
nets end to end now it's a bit different
from the usual end-to-end training
because
we don't have an objective the objective
we're trying to optimize is not
tractable actually
um but
we can sample these trajectories which
i think of like sampling thoughts like
our thought process is going through
some chain of explanation it's not a
complete and it doesn't represent all
the explanations but but uh what we
found with our training objectives for
g-funnes is that these sort of random
randomized um
kind of views of the world are
sufficient
uh to give a training signal to the
neural nets that do the the real job
yeah i'm curious so this trade-off
between exploration and versus
exploitation
and this has come up in so many contexts
you know throughout our show and one in
particular as we talked to you know
we've talked to multi-armed bandit
um folks right and and g-flow nets seem
to capture this balance between
exploration and exploitation
but the multi-armed bandit folks you
know they dive deep in that research
circle into this into this trade-off and
i think they have um some very
principled ways and even very rigorous
ways to analyze
this fundamental trade-off to what
extent do you think that that their
research
maybe could be applied to future
g flow net
variations like do you think maybe it
might open up more options to fine-tune
the trade-off between exploration and
exploitation
yeah i mean the the the bandit research
is very very closely related to the
g-flow net thread
um the g flow nets as we have been using
them for example for drug discovery they
are bandits uh it's just that the action
space is not you know one out of n
things
it's uh it's combinatorial because you
you build these pieces so the the action
space is not something you can enumerate
so you can't apply the the typical
band data algorithms but a lot of the
math is is totally applicable
and in fact what we use in the drug
discovery
setting
is a ucb
upper confidence-bound
objective
to learn a a good
exploration policy
so uh and that comes out of the bandit
research um
it what it does is it
you know it combines
the um the risk and reward expected
reward uh quantities together in a way
that
in theory uh guarantees that you will do
an efficient exploration and and find
that where where is the
you know
where's the money
where's the reward right all of the
possible places where you can get the
reward
so in in um
in the g flow net papers you often
describe it as you know we want to
sample not only the maximum reward path
in order to have more diversity in order
to maybe figure out something that we we
didn't know if we were just to go to the
maximum reward and that speaks a little
bit to the like the things that we know
that we don't know right we we maybe
know that
right this seems like a lower reward
trajectory it might turn out to be a
higher reward trajectory however
exploration and reinforcement learning
is also fundamentally addressing the
things about the things that i don't
know that i don't know which is where so
stuff like random exploration and things
like this uh comes in could you maybe
comment a little bit in how you see sort
of because it seems to me that if i
manage to sample according to what i
think is the reward distribution right i
i still have this problem of maybe there
is a deceptive rewards there are you
know i need to take a step back i may
not know some sort some
some area of the search space and don't
i just run into the same problems again
um so so the important
trick here um is you need your
model of the reward distribution
um or the reward function to be uh one
that captures uncertainty like uh maybe
in a bayesian way or you know whichever
way
the bayesian way by the way fits well
with the g flow net framework because we
can
um uh consider the
parameters of the reward function
as latent variables like you don't
actually know the reward function you're
trying to figure it out from experiments
so the g for that can
sample um
not just like what you should be uh
doing in order to acquire information
but also
um potential reward functions so you
know we we don't actually have a
knowledge of how the you know what's
going to be the rewards we're going to
get in the world
classical iol is going as you set to the
uh you know expected value and trying to
maximize that whereas
um the geophoning approach is trying to
acquire as much knowledge as possible
about the underlying reward function so
you're trying to minimize the
uncertainty
so you your model
with the g flow net is modeling the
uncertainty and then you can use it as a
reward for the policy that is going to
do action in the real world okay so
we're talking about different g flats
there's a g for that that models the
uncertainty in the reward in the that
you're gonna get from the real world
and that's like a bayesian model and
then you have another gefornet that
controls the policy that searches
and
its reward is how much uncertainty
reduction you're going to get by doing
this or that
so so yeah you you need to have a part
of your model that is
kind of uh aware of um the fact that
there are whole areas in the world that
you don't know about or aspects of the
world that you don't know about so that
you it can drive the exploration
i would love to know where some of the
magic is coming from um the promise of g
flow notes is that we can discover as
many modes as possible in the path
distribution traditionally in markov
chain monte carlo we had to hack priors
into the algorithm by hand you know to
find new modes or areas of information
efficiently especially when they are
very far apart or not very sharp the
hypothesis of g flow nets is that the
structure of these modes is learnable on
many problems even in high dimensions
it's a little bit like saying we're
getting a free lunch i mean actually i
think you used that exact phrase to
describe what we're doing here many
research avenues have tried to develop
general methods to discover these
structures and have failed how do you
think g flow nets will overcome this
seemingly intractable curse
there is no guarantee that they will
because if there is no structure in the
underlying function you're trying to
discover
so let's say the reward function or the
energy function that
you care about
then
having visited some finite number of uh
modes like regions where your reward is
high so
um it's not going to tell you anything
about what are the other good places the
other modes
so so there's no guarantee that it will
work but if if there is structure
then there is a free lunch and we know
machine learning is good at that like
the last 10 years of uh deep learning
and its success what is it telling us
it's telling us that you can generalize
right that these nets i'm not saying
they generalize perfectly
but they can generalize so you can think
of it like the the the the
machine learning problem is
um
given some examples of good things like
you know places where you got reward you
can you generalize to other places and
the supervised learning way of thinking
about it is you know given a candidate
place tell me how much reward i think i
would get the g for that sampler is
learning the inverse function it's going
to to sample but it's kind of the same
thing it's just going in the other
direction uh give me some
samples some some good places that that
you know where the reward is high
so
we now have a lot of experience in
designing powerful new nets
that can be leveraged
to generalize in those uh spaces where
we normally use ncmc and if there is
uh kind of regularities that are allowed
to generalize
um then all of that can be uh you know
put to use
we mentioned earlier reinforcement
learning often being applied in a
context where you have this kind of
solid reward function so let's say games
you know playing chess i'm really
curious what would happen hypothetically
if we applied g flow net you know to
something like chess so
i mean i think given the fact that
reinforcement learning like say alpha
zero is trained specifically to choose
the best move rather than
diverse moves it seems obvious that
maybe if given equal resources to both
alpha zero and flow zero alpha zero
would probably beat flow zero however i
think if flow zero were given more
resources say and train to the same
rating
say the same elo rating as alpha zero it
seems like flow zero if you would would
play significantly more diverse and
interesting games with a wider
variety of styles and i think you could
even imagine also that it could be
possible
even if given equal resources but
sufficiently high enough resources
that a hypothetical flow zero would
consistently reach higher ratings
because it might find you know more
interesting stepping stones
they have the potential to avoid
deception because it can explore
seemingly
lower reward paths that ultimately
develop into higher reward more curious
if you have any thoughts on that
yeah
um
it's a good question
i would say where
the kind of approach we've been
pioneering with g flow nets uh might be
really paying off
is if you
think about it from the perspective of
the learner has a finite computational
you know amount of resources because
in principle right if you had infinite
compute
and you know the reward function like
the the rules of chess or go then you
could just crank and find you know the
the policy that's best in every possible
setting
now
if you have finite resources like you
know you you have a budget of compute
um you'd like to use it efficiently
and so
that's where the exploration
exploitation trade-off becomes important
and um if you
if you had um
a
say a current policy that you're not
completely sure is the right one
and uh and then you're trying to say
well what
how should i play
so that i'm going to improve my policy
the most as then i'm going to reduce
the uncertainty that you know it is the
right policy like that it picks the
right things
so now we're getting closer to the kind
of setting where it makes sense to use g
flow nets
and then what i would expect
if we do
the engineering work here
um but based on the sort of much simpler
problems we've looked at is that it
would converge faster so given
um if you look at on the
uh x axis the number of
games you're playing
and on the y-axis how good is your
policy measured like on other games
so that's where you would gain in other
words it's the learning curve that you
might gain on asymptotically everything
is going to converge the optimal chest
layer right
so the the place where it's interesting
is to look at the learning curve how
fast you learn and here you want a sort
of active learning thinking like well
i'm not just trying to win here
i'm trying to gather information
so that
i'll win more in the future
and it's a different objective right and
that's where you need diversity and
exploration and like a model of your own
uncertainty and and an active learning
policy right
how much do do you think this could be
uh part of
not maybe only reward maximization
things but uh information collection uh
things like
i'm i'm sure you're you're thinking
about uh in let's say the brain there is
there's sort of maybe a similar process
going on and what do i still need to
retrieve in order to give certain
answers to questions or maybe in our
let's say a big search engine let's just
name one for naming sake let's google or
so would would uh try to answer your
query not by just searching through
their index but by actively doing this
multiple multiple things like is this
enough is this enough is this enough uh
do you see connections to these types of
things or
are they inherently different because
they're they might be not learning on
the spot
what they're
doing on the spot is acquiring
information
and you want to do it in an efficient
way and that's where sort of the active
learning thinking comes in
and
i think it's actually a very big
practical problem in deployment of like
ai dialogue systems that are not chit
chat but are
trying to say help a user achieve you
know get something get information or
something like this this is this there's
a huge need for this in you know the
business world and and uh and search
engines and you know it's much more than
search engines
um so i don't think we have the
algorithms that do that right now
and it's kind of painful the the human
has to know you know is driving
um but if um if we had systems that
could
explicitly model their own say
uncertainty about what the user needs or
wants
or where to find the information
um and then um and you need like pretty
powerful models of that like it's not
just galaxies they're simple things
that's where g flow net strengths comes
in you can represent very very complex
distributions over compositional objects
it's not just a
few numbers
um
then i think you could get to much more
efficient uh human machine interfaces
and
the same
i believe the same
methodology could be used more generally
in scientific discovery so what is
scientific discovery like what is it
that scientists do
they plan experiments that are going to
allow them to reduce the uncertainty
on their theories of you know some
aspect of the world it's the same
problem yeah you have a series of
questions you're allowed to ask to
nature
and you try to ask as few questions as
possible to as quickly as possible
understand what's going on
is there a connection fundamentally to
i'm thinking of causality which also
i've seen a number of papers that you've
collaborated on with people who are who
are deep into causality research and so
on um what what do you do you think
there is a
um
a a connection there where an agent
could learn to uncover if you think
about scientific discovery to uncover
the fundamental causal structure of the
world by asking such questions like
could there be a connection to that
branch of research and could this
finally be like the the unification of
of something machine learning and the
the world of causality
yes you guys are really asking all the
right questions thank you so much
um
in fact one of my main motivations for
the pursuing the the g flow net research
program
is that i think it's the uh it's an
ideal tool
for implementing
what i called in my talks um system two
inductive biases so what this
means is
there are lots of things we know from
neuroscience and cognitive science about
how we think
and we can bring that into the the
design
of uh probabilistic machine learning you
know based on deep learning is the
building blocks
and one of the inductive biases like one
of the characteristics of how we think
is we think causally we are constantly
asking the why questions we're trying to
find explanations and so on
and
and and that connects with classical ai
like uh the way we think
to some extent has also inspired
classical ai you know rules and and
logic and and reasoning and we haven't
yet found the way to integrate these
abilities in deep learning and of course
lots of people are like
trying to and and that's important
um but but i think the reason why
gfonets give us a an amazing handle on
this
is because
they they're really good at representing
distributions and sampling over graphs
and
and like a reasoning uh or a set of
possible reasoning to explain something
or to uh you know for planning
um they uh these are graphs um
and your thoughts can be seen as graphs
right so think of like uh maybe a simple
version of this think of a parse like a
semantic and and uh syntactic parse of a
sentence is a graph but usually it's you
know it's more than a tree there are all
sorts of symmetric connections including
with knowledge graphs right which also
graphs so the ability to
implicitly represent those distributions
and sample pieces of them as thoughts is
i think fundamental to how we think
and
going back to causality one of the hard
questions that i think g flawlets can
help us with is
causal discovery so in other words what
is the underlying cause structure of the
world including the uncertainty about it
given the things we observe
a lot of the research in causality has
been okay we observe these these uh
random variables discover
uh you know make inferences about you
know whether what we can say about
whether a equals b and so on
um but it's much harder to discover the
causal graph that that you know
in a large set of variables and it's
even harder and really nobody's done a
real job there
to do this when what the learner sees is
not the cost variables but just like low
level pixels and you also have to figure
out what are the causal variables and
how they are related causally and i
think g planets can help us do that
this this opens up this is so many
avenues of questions i think it would
probably almost be in a future episode
in itself but let me let me just ask you
about some of the basic ones which is um
as you mentioned kind of learning the
causality causality structure much more
difficult problem and uh the first
question is just how to represent the
causality and so you you mentioned
graphs you know graphs is one way and of
course you can develop um you know uh
isomorphic ways of representing
certain parts of logic as graphs et
cetera depending on how you know how
rich you unmake graph structure
um but there's also the other issue of
you know when you're trying to build and
i think it's probably correct to call
this a world model right like we're
trying to build a positive that's the
word i use
okay great and i and i so i have one
quick question about that which is
you know to me
to some people world model is only the
discriminative function it's just that
you know probability of y given x to me
it's more general it's also the
structure of x is that is that also your
yes your view as well
yes okay and so in constructing those
those world models some of the um let's
say the push back
on on these type of generative
techniques from from folks that are more
skewed more towards the discriminative
side is hey look fine you're going to go
and try and build this generative model
it's going to be even more complicated
than this discriminative model because
it also has to learn
you know the structure on x but i think
the possible free lunch here
is that you can learn abstract structure
on on x and so if you learn these
abstract world models
throwing away all the nitty gritty that
doesn't really matter you can
potentially have very powerful
you know predictive encoding if you will
like what's what's your thoughts on that
oh i that's what i've been thinking for
almost 20 years
uh and one of the reasons why i've been
interested in deep learning as as a
way to think of discovering abstract
representations you know from uh the
early days of deep learning uh as in
like mid uh like 2005 or something
and um and in the paper that jan
mccarran i wrote about and and also
other papers i wrote with some of my
colleagues at uh juniors of montreal on
you know deep learning around 2010
they are all about that notion that we
would like um
these and scubas learning procedures to
discover these abstract
factors as we call them but now i think
it's not just the the factors like the
variables but it's also more importantly
even how they're related to each other
which in the cause of language is what
we call causal mechanisms
and um
so here's a fundamental way of thinking
about this if you don't introduce the
abstract kind of structure that exists
in the world then representing
p of x the input distribution
is is is very difficult it's it's uh
in other words you'll need a lot of data
to learn it and uh it's not going to be
generalizing very well the whole point
of abstraction is that it it gives you
very powerful abilities to generalize to
new settings including out of
distribution which is one of the hottest
topics in machine learning right now how
do we extend what we do
so that it generalizes well in new
settings
and thinking causally about these uh
abstract causal dependencies as the
things that are preserved across changes
in distribution like if
if i go to the moon
it's the same laws of physics but the
distribution is very different
how do i generalize you know across such
changes in distribution it's because the
learner um is us
you know if we if we were if we had the
right education
um has figured out
um the the underlying at least you know
enough of the underlying causal
mechanisms
that we can be transported in a
different
world but where it's the same
laws of physics and and we can predict
what's going to happen even though it
looks completely different from you know
our training environment
so uh
the the idea of abstraction is really
that
if you introduce abstractions the
description length of the data
becomes
way smaller and that's why you get
generalization
absolutely i'm fascinated by these
abstract categories i think it's the
most exciting thing in a.i i mean
douglas hofstadter spoke about cognitive
categories like the concept of sour
grapes for example to represent a
certain thing and
almost magically um our brain seems to
arrange these cognitive categories and
it's not entirely clear to me whether
they're an emergent phenomenon or
whether it's some other process but the
modes that you're discovering in g-flow
nets there are kind of category um these
cognitive categories that i just spoke
about are abstractions um also things
like causality and geometric deep
learning that they are kinds of
categories but i've always had this
intuition that deep learning doesn't um
learn the categories on its own it needs
humans to kind of put
priors into the model as we do with
geometric deep learning do you think
that that will always be the case or can
we have that meta level of learning
yes uh what i really want to do
is build machines that can discover
their own semantic categories abstract
ones that really help them understand
the world
and of course they're going to learn you
know better and faster if we help them
just like you know we teach kids we
don't let them discover the world by
themselves
but um
we we do have an ability to invent new
categories that's what scientists do all
the time right
uh or artists and and you know writers
and philosophers and scholars
and and ordinary people who find new
solutions to problems we do that all the
time our brain is a machine that
discovers new abstractions of course no
usually it's just like one little bit on
top of all the things we got from our
cultural uh uh you know input but but
that's the ability that we don't have
right now in machine learning and that
is going to i think uh be a huge
advantage so now we're not in
reinforcement learning we're not in
active learning we're talking about
unsupervised learning so we're talking
about
how
can a machine discover these often
discrete
concepts
that
somehow
help it
understand so in other words build a
compact understanding of lots of things
that generalize across many settings
and
um yeah that that's
that the path to build that is is
becoming more and more um
firm in my mind as as i move forward
with g flow nets
um so as a clue there was a paper we had
recently i think in europe's on uh
that's connected to the global workspace
theory that that says that it's about
discrete valued neural communication i
think is the title where um
the one interesting intuition here
that's connected to this is
if you
um
if you constrain the communication
between different modules say in the
brain or in machinonic system to use as
few bits as possible and discrete is the
way to get very few bits
um you can get better generalization
and and they're good reasons for that
that we try to explain in the paper but
but that's that's it you know there's a
clue here that uh discrete concepts
emerge as a way to get better
generalization
um you you mentioned before and in in
terms of discreteness um and what you
mentioned before with graphs being very
fundamental it connects a little bit
back to a paper that you i think
provocatively titled the consciousness
prior um where where you you connect
sort of the ideas of attention sparse
factor graphs language uh things being
discrete things being describable by
language right um and and i find that
all to be very interesting on the topic
of consciousness we we would be uh it
would not be appropriate for us to not
put this question to you so you're not
you're not very active on twitter which
um is probably why you're so productive
but
if currently there is a bit of a of a
thing happening on twitter namely uh
ilya sutskiver of of of openai has
tweeted out a seemingly innocuous uh
tweet saying
it may be that today's large neural
networks are slightly conscious
which has resulted in
uh quite a let's say a storm on of
people agreeing disagreeing obviously
he's he's talking about maybe you know
the large language models we have today
which do incorporate a lot of the things
you talk about they do incorporate
attention mechanisms lots of them
presumably it's all one needs
they do incorporate language they do
incorporate discreet things with you
know discrete tokens and so on
what do you make of a statement like
this it may be that today's large neural
networks are slightly conscious
well
this one fundamental problem with such
statements
which is we don't know what
consciousness really is
so i think we have to have a bit of
humility here
um
i can't say what elia is saying is true
or not i think that there's more to
consciousness than uh what we have in
these large language models by a big gap
but that being said and you know
we do need to work with our colleagues
in neuroscience and kind of science who
are trying to figure out what
consciousness is from a scientific
perspective and philosophers who are
helping also to make sense of that
landscape
um though uh
we have to be careful with the use of
those words and you know i i was a bit
liberal in the title of my paper um
and i learned a lot about consciousness
since then i learned uh that there's a
lot that we don't understand that at the
same time there are enough bits that we
know from from quantum neuroscience
that can
serve as inspiration for
how we could build machine learning
systems that have similar
say conscious processing machinery okay
let's not say consciousness but just
conscious processing machine because
that's less controversial
and by the way the word consciousness
has been taboo in most of science for
you know a long time
and it has become untap you know
detailed in uh neuroscience because
we're starting to be able to make
measurements of what's going on inside
your brain
while you're doing things consciously or
not and so on and distinguish the parts
that you're consciously aware of and the
parts that are there in your brain but
you're not conscious so we're trying to
we're starting to make a lot of progress
of what it means to be conscious of
something or not
um
and uh
you know i i i think this is a very
exciting and important scientific
question
um and
i would rather like work on exploring
hypotheses and theories to explain our
conscious abilities
uh rather than make bold statements
about whether
current neural nets are conscious or not
professor benjo we've we've got some
david chalmers on the show next month do
you have any questions that you would
put to him
i very much
like a hypothesis
about consciousness
that
michael graziano has put out
to help explain
the
qualia the
subjective experience part that chalmers
wrote
might be something science can't really
you know
uh touch
um
and so what's you know i'd like to hear
what he has to say about these kinds of
approaches and one of the basic premise
here
is um
it is very grounded in things we can do
uh scientifically it's it's to say well
let's not try to figure out what is
consciousness or subjective experience
more specifically
um you know from
philosopher's chairs but let's let's
consider that as a phenomenon that
is happening in the brain i mean unless
you believe in sort of supernatural
things if it is happening something is
happening in the brain and we can report
about it and we can we can like
measure what's going on in various parts
of your brain while this is happening
and then you know can we um
then
uh
come up with theories that explain
why we feel that we have subjective
experience it's not saying whether
consciousness exists or not or subject
it's not whether it exists or not in
some sort of philosophical sense it's
whether you know what is it that's going
on in our brain that gives us that
feeling and then make us say
well i i'm you know
uh i'm conscious of x y and z
um
so so that's the that's the direction i
find interesting because it it opens the
door for a scientific investigation and
and michael graziano has a specific
theory
uh about
that which i find compelling that is
really rooted in the idea that
we have a world model
and then we we because we have an
attention that focuses only parts of it
at a time
and we need to have like a little
mini world model that controls that
attention uh that creates a sort of
separation
between um
uh
the the the where the real knowledge is
and then sort of this more abstract
control
machinery uh that could well
give us this illusion of uh cartesian
dualism which i think is is an illusion
but but you know must be grounded in
some uh
uh you know biological uh
uh
um
reality and that's i think understanding
that
is is a very good question to ask and
i'd like to get to know what he thinks
about such a research program
thank you very very cool
yeah thank you um i do have one kind of
nitty-gritty question because uh and
partly partly based on some of your
recent work i'm becoming more of a fan
of semi-supervised
learning and
you know you had a recent paper uh that
was on interpolation consistency
uh training
and what i found interesting about that
is that if we consider
one of the biggest challenges that we
face in in machine learning pretty much
across the board is an overcoming the
various you know curses if you will the
various forms of intractability that we
have in empirical learning methods
and in this context of semi-supervised
learning uh that recent paper uh it
found significant improvements over
state of the art by
forcing linearity so in this case it was
by this mix-up between the
unlabeled samples and they're they're
interpolated um fake labels
and in the last decade we've also seen
release come to dominance in the field
of neural networks they're piecewise
linear
uh recent work by randall um
bellistriero
developed an interesting frame of
reference which casts multi-layer
perceptrons
as a decomposition method which produces
a honeycomb of linear cells
in the ambient space and they're
activated turned off or on by input
examples
so my question is why is linearity
whether it's piecewise or otherwise
dominating the state-of-the-art in
approximation methods it almost seems to
me like we've kind of gone
back to the future if you will sort of
leaving behind attempts at more
smooth non-linear methods and gone back
to newer albeit more complicated
forms of linear approximation
right um i would say
uh something that's roughly linear is
simpler right so having a regularizer
that says oh you want to be roughly
linear or locally linear at least to to
as much extent as you can is a
smoothness prior right so that's going
to help generalization
but it could also hurt if
that is too strong and so having this
piecewise linear kind of more
type of solution
is a good compromise it says as few
pieces as possible
and ideally organized in a compositional
way so that it's not just like a rel
it's it's more like uh
the uh you know discrete abstract logic
you know reasoning
things sitting on top that's controlling
the pieces
um but but otherwise fairly simple in
each how each of the pieces are you know
like linear for example so one way to
look at this is if you look at class
the kind of rules that classical ai
researchers were using each rule is
fairly simple it's
you know like
it's almost linear or it's very simple
logic
but it's the composition of all those
rules
that gives the power of expression of
these systems of course the problem then
is that they didn't know how to train
them properly
um
but um
[Music]
yeah i i think um
we
um
i think we learn
to
um
come up with these discrete
ways of breaking up uh things into
simpler pieces
and that um
in fact i think if you're patient about
it it just comes out naturally and
they're very very weak assumptions
so in a way it's it's it's almost
it is piece-wise abstraction so we're
really kind of back yes that's what i
would lean to
rather than piecewise linear but linear
of course is a
broad part of you know it's an easy way
to get simple
amazing professor benjamin i'm
interested in your personal journey so
we've been talking about diverse
trajectories and i wanted to know about
your own trajectory of research over the
last 10 years now one of my mates a
psychologist and symbolist professor
gary marcus presumably one of your best
friends by the way he pointed out in his
2012 new yorker article that mlps lacked
ways of representing causal
relationships such as between diseases
and their symptoms and i think this has
been a significant focus of yours in
recent years as we've discussed and um
he thought at the time that you were a
bit too quote system one all the way
and uh he spoke then about the need for
heterogeneous architectures and the
acquisition of abstract concepts
compositionality and extrapolation which
i think has also been a huge focus of
yours in the last decade or so we've
really enjoyed watching your debate with
marcus um and by the way we would love
to host v2 of that debate so if you're
interested you just let us know we'll do
that but he's often viewed as a heretic
and you know just forgetting about
symbols versus neural networks for a
minute am i right in thinking that
you've converged in at least some ways
in your thinking and how would you
characterize that from your perspective
so
yeah
i
used to be in the 90s uh
a
uh you know pure neonet
sub-symbolic uh connectionist
uh researcher
and
i did my
grad studies
at a time on neural nets at a time when
the dominant
way of thinking was these you know
classical ai rule-based system with no
learning at all and was dominant meaning
that
the little group like you know jan and
jeff and i and others uh who were
thinking otherwise
um had to you know
defend our views and uh
and maybe that led to a kind of uh you
know
us versus them
uh i think unhealthy
uh way of thinking
and of course i matured
and
um
one of the big
so there i think there are several
turning points on that journey
um well one of them in in the in the
2000s was the realization of the
importance of abstraction so
and and the way to think about this
maybe more concretely because what does
it mean to be abstract is that i was
thinking well
what would be the right kind of
representation we want to have at the
top level of our unsupervised deepness
because we were doing mostly like
unsporalized deepness like you know deep
bose machines and stuff and and that
decade
and i was thinking well it would be
things like words
right things like the sort of concepts
that we manipulate at the top level well
it's words or you know the equivalent
maybe um with uh disambiguated
um
but
yeah we it didn't seem that we have the
right tools for that and then it
remained like an objective
and then in
2014 uh
we discovered uh the power of attention
um and and now it's closely connected to
abstraction because
what it does is it focuses on a few
things and of course that's our you know
that's very much a characteristic of how
we think a thought has very few elements
in it that means we have selected those
elements and that's where attention
comes in so it's getting closer to this
ideal of
building machines that think like humans
and then of course in 2017 i wrote this
consciousness prior paper where you know
i discovered all the work on global
workspace theory and and it you know and
the momentum is built up and of course
now
uh
you know humans think and they use
symbols and they understand the
very
uh abstract relationships between them
and we need to build neural nets that
can do that
so i guess where um i've maybe departed
uh from gary but maybe he's moved too is
um
it's gonna be neural nets that do it
right it's just that we're gonna be
training them in a special way and
that's what g-flownet's really aiming at
so can i just say we um we asked many
guests these these questions about their
their evolution and sometimes they they
tend to be spicier than others but i
have to say from my perspective your
answer was the most informative
the most gracious and the most noble uh
of of answers that we've heard so far to
similar questions so
uh kudos to you that was awesome thanks
i just cannot believe it and we always
do a hell of a lot of preparation but
it's got to the point now where we know
that we're not going to get more than
about six questions in so we you know we
kind of like exponentially you know have
an exponential prior on our questions
well he was awesome though with like you
know we asked him to to give relatively
sort of three-minute answers and and he
stuck to that which was really cool i
mean that's
that's very helpful to have an
interesting dialogue and i i can't
believe how proud i am you know that
he's that he appreciates that we put the
prep time into it and uh you know had
had decent questions that were hopefully
interesting for him
as well as our um as well as our
audience
so dr kilcher light speed culture what's
your take
it's cool he's i mean he's um
yeah i think his is the the thing he
mentioned at the end like his humility
it kind of shines through everything
yeah he does and he answers he's like
you know here's the best answer i can
give uh but you know
um he seems to be very
like open and not not um
not very
yeah one notices he's not on twitter
it's like it's no that was a brilliant
question
i i think we should post that question
on our twitter
uh because you know that there's that uh
a bit for people watching this in a
year's time it's probably forgotten
about but yeah that ilia guy from open
ai said that the models might be
slightly conscious i was exasperated by
that
uh because i i watched his interview on
lex and i know but by saying bad things
about him he will never come in our
podcast but i don't think he would have
done anyway so it doesn't matter but um
yeah i think that
it's pretty bad
what do you say that why exactly yeah
why it's like it's like oh you don't
think it's bad no
he says i i think
because a lot of the folks at open ai
they are um you know like in the
rationalist community and they and they
seriously believe that we're an imminent
threat of um the ai taking over the
world and us being paper clips and i
think it's next i listened to his
interview on lex and he sounded like a
salesman
talking about codex and how it was going
to revolutionize everything and i i
honestly think that there's just such a
divergence between
what they're saying in reality right now
well not to to drift to drift too far
away from from from our guests today uh
but um so i thought i thought it was
just kind of a shower thought you know
like you know um the the large neural
networks of today might be a little bit
conscious right and and and you're just
like yeah well yeah well
and it is a shower thought like it's on
twitter it's just something you you
tweet out and
and it brings up interesting questions
like he brings up interesting questions
like you know you're a you're a ball of
neurons like you're just a slap together
piece of matter right you have
consciousness so clearly
like something about you know
learning systems combined with data or
maybe not even combined with data gives
rise to consciousness so why can't
why can't another you know
in silico uh slap together system of
neurons
ingested with data be slightly conscious
or have like some properties like and
that's that's essentially
yeah uh benjamin refused to give
like a you know humble the humble person
he is he refused to give like you know
the the the strong take on that but that
would have because i he might just this
is my opinion not his obviously but
reading the consciousness prior paper
it is not too far off he formulates
consciousness as having these elements
of you know i have my internal state
which is sort of everything in my brain
that i could bring bring up into my
forefront then i get some input from the
outside world and through the input i
then filter like with an attention
mechanism i do i look what in my mind
could i now bring into focus right
and that is by use of something like an
attention mechanism and then i take that
thing and i
put it into these abstract concepts i i
use i represent
um i represent the concepts in my head
as a sparse factor graph and by focusing
on parts of that i can then make
inferences in this sparse factor graph
and so on now obviously something like
gpt3 doesn't have all of that at least
not explicitly but some of it is there
right it's you know i have a piece of
input i have a giant amount of weight so
i use an attention mechanism to sort of
see what i can focus on
yeah but yeah but i think that i think
that's a very declarative description of
consciousness
and at its roots it's about the
phenomenological experience right and i
know we discussed computationalism and
pan-psychism let's not go down that
rabbit hole but surely
they don't think that this model can
feel well but so this is consciousness
is not about feeling yeah it's about
being being like aware of of like
ex oh i don't even know what it is i'm
just saying
that
it sounded not too far away from what
the consciousness prior paper was about
and yes i realize it's called the
consciousness prior and not
consciousness but you know
yeah i mean i think he answered it the
way a scientist should answer it and and
i was really happy with his answer which
is
okay a
consciousness has to be some activity
of neurons and firings or whatever in
the brain or else we're talking about
magic and that's not in the in the field
of science
and b you know whatever that thing is
it's obviously quite nuanced and
complicated and we don't have we don't
know yet so
we need to have some humility here which
means we shouldn't be alarmist so we
don't need to be going and you know
you know burning books tomorrow because
because we created a you know gpt
whatever that anytime its wheel is
spinning and it's actually suffering you
know if you ask it a question that's too
hard and it's spinning it's because
you're hurting it and it's suffering and
so we need to turn it off like right
away but wait we can't turn it off
because then we'd be like murdering you
know a sentient being or something like
we're way way too
in our infantile understanding
of you know this type of complex
complex behavior that's the human mind
and consciousness to be at that point so
from my perspective he he answered it
completely 100 scientifically and
there's a lot of folks out there
who are supposed to be scientists that
spend a lot of time
with you know unscientific you know
thinking about it
cool um
let's talk let me one of the um
the things that i really found
interesting about benjo's ideas
other than the the causality stuff and
and the system two stuff um is this
notion of diversity
we've had conversations with kenneth
stanley all about open-endedness and
diversity preservation
we've also had conversations with
fristen um about the importance of
balancing relative entropy and so on and
we have all of these curses in empirical
learning right the the statistical
curses the approximation curses um
dimensional yeah we have to mention
dimension
dimensionality and even i mean you know
we're talking about curses and the uh
monty you know the mark of chain monte
carlo in in the sense of it being a high
dimensional space and we we need to
assume that there's some structure
around where these modes are uh so all
of these approaches are ways of
simultaneously um you know being able to
explore but not being cursed so yeah
what's your take on that
well anyone well my my take was that um
that uh
i i like that he's so interested in
abstraction because um
you know to me that that's been not only
one you know it's not only one of the
larger mysteries at least for me i mean
i don't know of the uh kind of the
universe is
abstraction idealism you know platonic
thinking whatever i mean the whole point
is just that he views abstraction as a
key to
pragmatically useful you know pass
forward and
it's a hard problem a really hard
problem and you know his focus right now
is on
kind of graph based um structures and
and i have to admit you know for me too
they're quite seductive and appealing i
don't know if they're the
the right path forward but it's
definitely cool to see a lot of research
looking into graph based you know
methods
or you know hyper graph based methods
whatever they are they seem to
definitely be
a promising path forward and i think
we're in for
hopefully if we can continue to progress
at a reasonable rate you know some some
interesting uh decades ahead
i mean i would i would also postulate
that maybe
um our most of our let's say benchmarks
that we're thinking about today aren't
necessarily suited to
to
because his argument was by creating
abstractions it might actually you know
help your ability to learn something
right which is a thing that we all
intuitively understand in the world if i
have good abstractions i can transfer my
knowledge from here to here and from
here to here yeah in something like
imagenet classification or whatnot or
most of the benchmarks we have today the
necessity of abstractions is probably
not
like the data
the hardness of the problem probably
doesn't require
abstractions to be introduced and
therefore
the limiting factor here might not only
be the models themselves but also let's
say our ability to even measure
uh
the the progress one could make with
abstractions and i think that's gonna
change maybe in in the near future
because people are going into
multi-modality
uh research and so on and there i think
the concept of um sort of concepts
maybe not abstractions but at least
something like concepts is way more more
uh important
yeah there there's let me just follow up
real quick there tim because there's
something very interesting there to
yannick which is
the lack of good tools to deal with
multimodal you know sets of data results
and a lot of times we're just throwing
out kind of valuable valuable sources of
data just because you know
we don't have a good tool sets to do
with them like think about the
self-driving car like the whole
should it be vision versus lidar debate
why why isn't it both i mean you know if
you confirm five dollars you can throw
on some cheap you know
lidar sensors or something maybe not
something fancy but something cheap why
wouldn't we take advantage
of that data and it's it's really
because we don't have good tools to deal
with
with multimodal data
we got to
a good point in the discussion where we
were talking about the nature of finding
abstractions
and i wonder where the neural networks
can find abstractions now the the
cynical view is that humans kind of
create these inductive priors and they
represent the abstraction so certainly
in the case of geometric deep learning
and that's kind of what's happening we
put the um the priors in there to reduce
the size of the approximation space and
keith and i had an interesting idea
yesterday there's a kind of analogy
between geometric deep learning and
causal representation learning so i
think keith you went online and you
found a really interesting definition of
a causal model which is that it's kind
of immune to
let's say adversarial examples so what a
model does right now is it learns a
relationship essentially between let's
say every single pixel and something
happening right which is why that model
is vulnerable
yeah so that was the uh there then
yannick would love to get your comments
on that but that was um
yeah this paper and i could go dig it up
but i'm not gonna get the reference
right now where it said uh
you know hey what is the difference
between a causal
look or a prediction from a causal model
versus a prediction from a non-causal
model and the point was that well almost
by definition really if you have a
causal model
then
if you perturb the inputs the prediction
that you get out of it remains a valid
a valid output because after all if it's
a causal model and it's reflective of
sort of the causal structure of the
world or whatnot then sure that's a
valid valid output whereas if it's
non-causal it has the potential to learn
all these kind of spurious
spurious structures and therefore that's
why you get the capability of these
adversarial examples where you just you
know put a little rainbow pixel
somewhere in it and it messes up the
class because it had this the spurious
connection i mean in the same vein you
could also it the adversarial examples
are there because of of inaccuracies
because we don't have the perfect
discriminative function right i could
also say well if i just had the correct
discriminative functions it doesn't need
to be causal if i just had like the the
right partitioning of my input space
then you know i'm super not vulnerable
to adversarial attacks i i guess the the
real question would be
would that
technically amount to a causal model if
i had you know the the perfect
partitioning of the input space into my
classes i don't i don't know that's
like is there like a mathematical
equivalent from that to a causal model
who knows
right yeah i think there's probably it's
it's probably um
certainly um if you have the perfect
discriminative function it's probably
the discriminative function that you
would derive from a causal model i'm not
100 sure you can go
go into reverse because i imagine there
probably is some some information loss
going from
you know a causal model to um
you know like for example i'll give you
an example um in in the cases of say
production systems you know so so these
little
rewriting rules or whatever the
definition there of a causal
system
is one in which all the potential
graphs all the potential transition
graphs that you can get to a particular
output are isomorphic
so even though you have you can have
like the perfect discriminative kind of
function
there may be multiple possible graphs
that you could have gotten there but
they're isomorphic so i'm not quite sure
you know how that would translate into
this
this this point
but i think you'd be just as good for
the purpose of discriminating
i think it's related to the semantics
discussion we're having in nlp so
people like walled suburbs say that
neural networks don't have semantics and
in in the same way as i was just saying
blue pixels i mean in the real world
let's say male testosterone levels is
causally linked to
um incidence of car crashes which means
you can now take the model in in holland
in a different country and because it's
a causal factor it will extrapolate in
in the same way but neural networks
models because what a human does is we
would
come up with the right representational
abstraction we would build a model which
is very reductionist a neural network
models everything to everything and the
semantics are all one thing well
okay i don't i'm not i'm not too
too keen on
discussing like semantics and whatnot
with with nlp people but um
why not i don't i don't know
you know like like
i don't know it often it often veer
veers away and
and it
fears into something it's like it's a
bit tears into semantics you know i i i
like what what i think connor connor lay
he said like when we talked him along
oh he wouldn't he wouldn't like that i
talked to him a long time ago and i
happen to agree with him there is that
you sort of have to see everything from
the perspective of these models like if
i'm a gpt-3 my entire world is text
input right and people can't somehow
judge dpt3 by well you don't even have
whatever a connection to the real world
you don't even know that you don't go
see a doctor if your plant is sick right
like
how can you not know that like okay they
don't live in the real world they live
in the text world of the internet and in
that world i'm not sure if there is not
a level of abstraction happening in
these models like i
it's it's
it's um
yeah i i i'm i i don't wanna i don't
wanna claim
that these things do not form
abstract
things it might not be the same abstract
classes that we form but they definitely
form some level of abstraction and of
course they can't transfer it because we
only give them the one modality right
but they may be able to transfer it
between you know different
areas of text uh which they sometimes do
right and yeah so that's i i just
wouldn't be
so conclusive with respect to these
things that that's true i think we've
gone full circle now so after speaking
with randall bellistrio about the
splines
that almost
results in such a cynical reading of
mlps that they're just hash tables but
we're not using mlps we're using
transformers and we're using cnns and
actually if you think of abstraction
just as being extrapolation i think they
are basically synonymous it's about
being able to
extrapolate outside of your training set
um then those inductive priors are
indeed um producing abstractions but the
problem is humans design those inductive
priors what we want is to learn
abstractions and that's the thing that i
don't think is happening i'm kind of um
i'm kind of on the same page as yannick
and connor on the one hand which is
hey if an abstraction is just a a
compression you know encoding
of um the input space then of course
they're learning abstractions right i
mean they are throwing away
you know information and retaining some
some abstract thing i think but i think
that just kind of devolves into
somewhat like um
you know uh
bastardization if you will of what
people mean when they say abstractions
because the types of abstractions that
traditionally we think about as
abstractions are simplifications
you know they're they're like
simplifications of more general longer
range
kind of structures whereas we know and i
think we all know this for sure that
a lot of the quote unquote abstractions
that did a neural network learns
are these kind of like shortcuts right
they're like these low level borderline
spurious kinds of abstractions and
that's why they break so easy that's why
they're so brittle and i mean there is
this vagueness here right like when is
an abstraction a good attraction i don't
know but i think it all kind of in a way
misses the point like
what we're talking about here is that um
and this is a lot of what bingio said
right which is that the goal here
is to figure out how to get
uh machine learning to learn
structures that by virtue of their
simplification their simple abstractions
are more generalizable out of
distribution
right like that's that's really kind of
the goal here and
i mean so the rest of it is just
semantics
pun intended i mean
if you look
across the world
a lot of let's say cultures and humans
and so on must have the same
abstractions
right
so
it must mean a little bit that
it's not just something you learn during
your lifetime right so um
right oh absolutely so i'm correct it's
it's learned by the it's learned by
evolution by the species by by life yeah
itself exactly right but but is
like the the analogy to us building in
the correct ones as a shortcut for just
evolution doing it using essentially
random search right that is
it might right it's it's a different
it's a different quality of
we want machines to learn something
because usually we think of when we say
we want machines to learn something is
we want him to ingest data akin to maybe
what a human does during its
lifetime
but the when you know the these sort of
abstractions and the ability to form
abstractions they seem to be happening
on a more fundamental shared level yes
you just put the pin in the center of
the bullseye i think that's exactly
right
you know there's a lot to be said for i
mean it's an epi phenomenon
and
a lot of intelligence is embodied
and i agree that there's an awful lot of
stuff going on
um
unbeknown to us with this clearly
something that most people don't have a
grasp on um maybe this is why uh at the
population level maybe this is why i'm
frequently miscommunicating with people
because i never assumed that learning
was about
you know what a human being learns in a
human being's lifetime like it's to me
it's always been the evolution
you know paradigm that's like what's
encoded in your neurons what's encoded
in your dna you know
uh what was learned by bacteria a long
time ago and how did that translate into
what human beings are doing so i don't
know why like why so many people are
focused on
what a human being learns in their
lifetime i mean it's more
you know why is that the goal i'm not
sure i know but we we run the risk of
being very reductionist because conor
leahy said that it's an open question
whether humans are even intelligent and
if you go down that line
very quickly you you start saying oh
human beings are just hash tables like
gbt3 clearly humans are intelligent in
some way well you can just take it as a
you know matter of definition but it's
not a binary thing like again why are we
always into this black and white concept
something is or is not intelligent like
that's not how i view things i think
there's a spectrum of
of intelligence from like
zero to i don't know maybe infinity or
something some really large number
beyond what what human beings are
and so it's this this continuum so
that's why i like chalet is kind of on
the measure of intelligence because
even though it doesn't actually give us
a you know quantitative way yet to
measure intelligence it at least is
thinking along the right directions
which is how do you measure
intelligence and how do you define it
as a category of activity um and then we
can kind of get past this black and
white you know thinking
well gentlemen
always a pleasure absolutely yeah
absolutely